I'm Jo and I work as an assistant practitioner in a CAMS service in Lancashire. I bought and read Marianne's book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to accompany me while completing the clinical psychology training application. It proved to be really good company. I found it sparked ideas of how to build experience and skills, but more than that, it offered the chance to get lost in people's stories. It provided a timely reminder not to get so caught up in an end goal and to value and enjoy each job we fulfill along the way because the work we do now is important and matters to those we sit
我是Jo，我在兰开夏郡的一家CAMS服务机构担任助理医师。我购买并阅读了Marianne的书《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective），以此陪伴我完成临床心理学培训的申请。事实证明，它确实是很好的陪伴。我发现它激发了我关于如何积累经验和技能的想法，但更重要的是，它让我有机会沉浸在人们的故事中。它及时提醒我，不要太执着于最终目标，而要珍惜并享受我们一路走来所履行的每一份工作，因为我们现在所做的工作很重要，对我们身边的人以及我们自己都很重要。
alongside as well as ourselves. It also gave the reassurance that there are eclectic roots into clinical psychology, which is important for me as someone who's had a meandering journey and not a typical route to the profession. I wholeheartedly recommend the book for both personal and professional reasons. Be prepared to put evening tasks on hold for a while though, because once you've started reading it's tough to put it down. What if I told you that your fear of death might be quietly shaping your choices, your relationships, even your worldview? In today's episode we are diving into the psychology of death anxiety. What it is, how often it crops up and what happens when it starts to interfere
它也让我确信，通往临床心理学的道路是多元的，这对于像我这样经历过曲折、而非典型职业道路的人来说非常重要。我衷心推荐这本书，无论是出于个人还是职业原因。不过，要做好暂时搁置晚间任务的准备，因为一旦开始阅读，就很难放下了。如果我告诉你，你对死亡的恐惧可能正在悄悄地塑造你的选择、你的人际关系，甚至你的世界观，你会怎么想？在今天的节目中，我们将深入探讨死亡焦虑的心理学。它是什么，它出现的频率如何，以及当它开始干扰日常生活时会发生什么。
with daily life. Whether you've ever had a passing fear of dying or you find yourself avoiding the topic completely, you're not alone. And the good news, there are always ways to find more peace and to work through this. And stick around right to the end because we are sharing a top tip for thinking about your own mortality and helping you to have more control. Hope you find it super useful. If you do, please like and subscribe for more. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. Thank you for being here and if you are watching on YouTube, please do bear in mind that currently only 11.2% of you are subscribed to the channel.
无论你是否曾有过对死亡的一闪而过的恐惧，还是发现自己完全在回避这个话题，你都不孤单。好消息是，总有办法找到内心的平静并克服这一点。请坚持听到最后，因为我们将分享一个关于思考自身死亡率并帮助你获得更多掌控感的绝佳建议。希望你觉得它非常有用。如果觉得有用，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是Marianne Trent博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。感谢你的收听，如果你是在YouTube上观看，请记住，目前只有11.2%的观众订阅了该频道。
Please do come along and subscribe to my channel Dr. Marianne Trent and watch the content, like, engage, comment, get involved, because it really does help me to create bigger and better content and secure bigger and better guests so that you get more from this podcast too. Following a show or subscribing to a YouTube channel really is the kindest thing you can do for any creator that you rate. So if you're not already following the show on your favourite podcast platform, please do. Okay, with no further ado, let's dive in, meet our guest for today, Tia, and I will
请务必订阅我的频道“Dr. Marianne Trent”，观看内容、点赞、互动、评论、参与其中，因为这确实能帮助我创作更大更好的内容，并邀请到更大更好的嘉宾，这样你也能从这个播客中获得更多。关注节目或订阅YouTube频道确实是你对任何你欣赏的创作者能做的最贴心的事。所以，如果你还没有在你最喜欢的播客平台上关注这个节目，请务必关注。好了，废话不多说，让我们开始吧，去见见我们今天的嘉宾Tia，我会在
see you on the other side. Hi Tia, welcome along to the podcast. It's lovely to have you here. Thank you so much for having me. Hello Marianne and everyone. Thank you for being here. So we are thinking today about kind of where you are right now, which is that you are an end stage trainee clinical psychologist who yesterday completed her VIVA and PASS. Congratulations. And we are thinking about specifically your research today,
另一端等你。嗨Tia，欢迎来到播客。很高兴你能来。非常感谢你的邀请。你好Marianne，大家好。感谢你的到来。所以我们今天在思考你现在的处境，也就是你是一名即将结业的临床心理学实习生，昨天刚刚完成了你的VIVA（论文答辩）并顺利通过。恭喜你。我们今天特别关注你的研究，
which is on death anxiety. Is that right? Yes, that's right. Amazing. So what is death anxiety? I mean, death anxiety really is the fear or the unease about our own death or the dying process and this can show up as worry of losing control or you know the unknown because we don't, most of us don't know what's going to happen after we pass and kind of what happens after life. And it, you know, can be a quite common thing as well. Of course some people experience it at some point, but we don't really talk about it very much. So that's kind of where the research stemmed from. OK, so we're not necessarily thinking specifically
是关于死亡焦虑的，对吗？是的，没错。太棒了。那么什么是死亡焦虑呢？我的意思是，死亡焦虑实际上是对我们自身死亡或死亡过程的恐惧或不安，这可能表现为对失去控制的担忧，或者你知道，对未知的恐惧，因为我们大多数人不知道我们去世后会发生什么，以及生命结束后会发生什么。而且，你知道，这也可能是一件很常见的事情。当然，有些人会在某个时刻经历它，但我们并没有真正谈论它。所以这就是研究的起源。好的，所以我们不一定是在专门思考
about people who might have a palliative diagnosis or who think that they might not live as long as people around them. We're thinking about the general kind of Dawson's Creek style existential ponderings of our own mortality. Is that right? That's exactly right, yes. I mean it's the one thing in life that is inevitable to all of us and that's exactly what the thesis focused on. Okay, absolutely. Can you tell us a bit more about your thesis then and the the terror management theory? What is that? Yeah, of course. So terror management theory is a psychological theory that
那些可能被诊断为姑息治疗，或者认为自己可能活得不如周围人长的人。我们是在思考那种一般性的、像《恋爱时代》（Dawson's Creek）风格的关于我们自身死亡率的生存主义思考。是这样吗？完全正确，是的。我的意思是，这是生活中对我们所有人来说都不可避免的一件事，而这正是论文所关注的。好的，绝对是。那么你能多告诉我们一些关于你的论文和恐怖管理理论（Terror Management Theory）的内容吗？那是什么？是的，当然。所以恐怖管理理论是一种心理学理论，
really tries to explain how we cope with the knowing that we will one day die and terror management theory states that because we're the only animal that's aware of their mortality, it's quite unique and hence the term terror. Because if we went through our life day to day just thinking about the fact that you know we will want Haces to exist, that is quite terrifying to think about. But the terror management theory states that basically we'll build up systems to buffer this terror, this fear, this death anxiety that we have. And we do this through systems like our culture, our personal values and relationships that act as buffers in a way. And these buffers give us a
它真正试图解释我们如何应对我们终有一天会死亡的认知。恐怖管理理论指出，因为我们是唯一意识到自己死亡率的动物，这是非常独特的，因此有了“恐怖”这个词。因为如果我们每天都在思考这样一个事实，即我们终将不复存在，那确实是非常可怕的。但恐怖管理理论指出，基本上我们会建立系统来缓冲这种恐怖、这种恐惧、这种我们所拥有的死亡焦虑。我们通过文化、个人价值观和人际关系等系统来做到这一点，这些系统在某种程度上充当了缓冲器。这些缓冲器给了我们一种
sense of meaning, they help us feel secure so that the death anxiety doesn't overwhelm us. It's a bit like having an emotional toolkit for that death awareness. Okay, so terror management theory, TMT, is that something that's your own baby or is that already in the literature? Oh no, that's been in the literature since I want to say like the 80s. It was three social psychologists who came up with this theory and it really started this idea of why do we need self-esteem. And that's kind of what I've really touched upon in terms of these buffers. So self-esteem help us buffer certain difficulties. One of those difficulties is
意义感，它们帮助我们感到安全，这样死亡焦虑就不会压垮我们。这有点像为这种死亡意识准备了一个情感工具箱。好的，所以恐怖管理理论（TMT），那是你自己的原创，还是文献中已经有的？哦不，自80年代以来，它就一直存在于文献中。是三位社会心理学家提出了这个理论，它真正开启了关于“为什么我们需要自尊”的想法。这就是我在这些缓冲器方面真正触及的内容。所以自尊帮助我们缓冲某些困难。其中一个困难就是
the awareness that we may one day die if we are living up to our worldviews or our values. It gives us a sense of meaning that life is worthwhile, that we are worthwhile people. That then buffers that anxiety through self-esteem. Okay. If things are going wrong and we have high kind of feelings about our own mortality, what might we be seeing in ourselves or perhaps in someone we care about or someone that we we work with clinically? Well, I mean, I think a lot of us fear death anyway, because it's a big unknown. Our brains try to keep us safe. It's a big don't get eaten machine, right? So it's normal to have these thoughts pop into our mind or to have reminders day to
意识到如果我们践行我们的世界观或价值观，我们终有一天会死亡。它给了我们一种意义感，即生命是有价值的，我们是有价值的人。这通过自尊缓冲了那种焦虑。好的。如果事情进展不顺利，我们对自己死亡率有很高的感受，我们可能会在自己身上，或者在我们关心的人，或者我们临床工作的人身上看到什么？嗯，我的意思是，我认为我们很多人本来就害怕死亡，因为这是一个巨大的未知。我们的大脑试图保护我们的安全。这是一个巨大的“别被吃掉”机器，对吧？所以这些想法出现在我们的脑海中，或者在日常生活中受到提醒是很正常的，
day, you know, you may see a scene on TV or hear about someone's passing. And that does trigger these thoughts of mortality or reflection on life in ourselves. But normally we are pretty good at buffering those thoughts, like I said, through those mechanisms. But for some people, they may have not had the opportunity to develop the buffers as well as others. For example, this could be from things like early loss, trauma, insecure attachment styles, kind of a lot of the things that we see in people who also develop mental health difficulties, you know, those early childhood adverse experiences.
你知道，你可能会在电视上看到一个场景，或者听到某人去世的消息。这确实会触发我们对自己死亡率的思考或对生活的反思。但通常我们很擅长缓冲这些想法，就像我说的，通过那些机制。但对于一些人来说，他们可能没有机会像其他人那样很好地发展这些缓冲器。例如，这可能源于早期丧亲、创伤、不安全依恋类型等，我们在那些也发展出心理健康困难的人身上看到的很多东西，你知道，那些童年早期的不良经历。
And when we don't have those buffers or perhaps we manage our mortality in a way that's not productive or not helping us, it can, or the literature at least, says that it can definitely lead to an increase in mental health difficulties. The research also states that death anxiety can be a transdiagnostic factor across different mental health disorders. Okay, yeah, and it is, it does crop up more than you might imagine so I don't know if you've ever read any of the Hunger Games books but I'm reading the new one at the moment the one that was published in 2025 and it's focusing in on Haymitch who in the first Hunger Games is Katniss's kind of mentor but it's focusing in on his story when he was in the Hunger Games and it's interesting one of the participants is kind of saying, actually, my hope is that I will die quickly
当我们没有这些缓冲器，或者也许我们以一种非生产性或无助于我们的方式管理我们的死亡率时，它可能，或者至少文献说，它肯定会导致心理健康困难的增加。研究还指出，死亡焦虑可以是跨不同心理健康障碍的跨诊断因素。好的，是的，它确实比你想象的出现得更频繁，所以我不知道你是否读过任何《饥饿游戏》的书，但我目前正在读最新的一本，那是2025年出版的，它聚焦于黑密奇（Haymitch），他在第一部《饥饿游戏》中是凯特尼斯（Katniss）的导师，但它聚焦于他在《饥饿游戏》中的故事，有趣的是，其中一名参赛者说，实际上，我的希望是我能死得快一点，
and that my family won't have to watch this protracted, horrific death. And that's almost hoping for that good death that we sometimes speak about. But obviously, in a game show, a good death is perhaps different than the millionaire's death, which I think is spoken about, which is lying in a bed when you're 100 surrounded by people that you love. That's kind of sometimes thought of as a millionaire's death. And then of course, Squid Games as well. Squid Games is around in our culture currently. I've just literally finished season three yesterday. Bit disappointed actually. But yeah, like thinking about people's death
这样我的家人就不必看着这种漫长、可怕的死亡。这几乎是在希望我们有时谈论的那种“好死”。但显然，在游戏节目中，好死可能与所谓的“百万富翁之死”不同，后者我认为是被谈论过的，即当你100岁时躺在床上，被你爱的人包围。这有时被认为是百万富翁之死。当然还有《鱿鱼游戏》。《鱿鱼游戏》目前在我们的文化中很流行。我昨天刚刚看完第三季。其实有点失望。但是的，就像思考人们的死亡，
and kind of whether that's quite a violent death or whether it's something actually that we hope we will live till our older years. We hope that we will, I guess, hit some of those milestones that are different for each of us, but certainly, you know, for many people might include finding a life partner or, you know, maybe having children or not having children or starting a business or, you know, making a success of your career, making yourself proud, making others proud. Like, you know, there's certain things that
无论是那种暴力的死亡，还是我们希望自己能活到老年的那种死亡。我们希望我们能，我想，达到我们每个人都不同的那些里程碑，但当然，你知道，对许多人来说，可能包括找到人生伴侣，或者，你知道，也许生孩子或不生孩子，或者创业，或者，你知道，在事业上取得成功，让自己感到骄傲，让别人感到骄傲。就像，你知道，有一些事情是
we might want to do. Some people might want to go on and become a grandparent or just like those self-imposed life goals. Is it measuring ourselves up to how well we feel we have or haven't measured up to those goals that leads to us having this terror response. Yeah, I think you're absolutely right there. So what the research also states, and I think what you started to describe here, we have different ways of dealing with our mortality. And of course, we have different worldviews. So for example, if we take religion into account, of course, that kind of gives us a quite nice framework to work from and sets out you know if you do certain things you will have a good life or perhaps you will go to heaven or be
我们可能想做的。有些人可能想成为祖父母，或者只是那些自我强加的人生目标。是因为衡量我们自己是否达到了这些目标，才导致我们产生了这种恐怖反应吗？是的，我认为你说得完全正确。所以研究也指出，我想你在这里开始描述的内容，我们有不同的方式来处理我们的死亡率。当然，我们有不同的世界观。例如，如果我们把宗教考虑在内，当然，这给了我们一个相当不错的框架，并规定了，你知道，如果你做某些事情，你就会有美好的生活，或者也许你会去天堂，或者在死后转世。然后，在宗教之外，我们也可以通过我们所谓的象征性或字面上的不朽来思考这些缓冲死亡焦虑的其他方式，而你所描述的拥有人生伴侣、拥有孩子，在某种程度上缓冲了死亡焦虑，因为我们的遗产得以延续，所以我们可以通过我们的孩子、通过我们的家庭活下去。所以从某种程度上说，这是一个非常好的缓冲。但我认为你所描述的也是正确的，即，如果你重视家庭和亲密关系，重视生活中的人际关系，并且你发现你正在，你正在满足生活中的那些价值观或目标，那么这
reincarnated after life. And then outside of religion we can also think about these other ways of buffering our death anxiety through what we call symbolic or literal immortality and what you've described of having a life partner, having children, in a way that kind of buffers the death anxiety because our legacy lives on so we can live on through our children, through our family. So in a way that is a really nice buffer to have. But I think what you're also describing is right in terms of, you know, if you value family and closeness, relationships in your life and you are finding that you are having, you are meeting those values or those goals in your life then that
确实会增加你的自尊，或者至少文献是这么说的。是的，这很奇怪，不是吗？因为我不认为我的祖父会准备好死亡。说“准备好死亡”可以吗？80岁。他在90岁生日那天在棚屋顶上修理它，所以他非常不像你对普通90岁老人所期望的那样。他95岁时去世了，但他那时已经非常满足了，就像他准备好了，就像他会说，我的妻子去世了，我的女朋友去世了，我所有的朋友都去世了。在我的书《悲伤集体》（The Grief Collective）中，戴夫（Dave），其中一位撰稿人，思考了生命之树、家谱，实际上随着我们
does increase your self-esteem or at least that's the reset of the literature states. Yeah and it's strange isn't it because I don't think my grandfather would have been ready to die. Is that an okay thing to say ready to die? 80. He spent his 90th birthday on his shed roof fixing it so he was like very much not what you'd expect for your average 90 year old. He died when he was 95 but he was so done by then, like he was ready, like he would say like well my wife died, my girlfriend died, all of my friends have died. And in my book, The Grief Collective, Dave, one of the contributors, thinks about kind of the tree of life, the family tree, and actually as we
成长，我们不再向上寻找家庭联系，我们开始不得不横向寻找。但最终那可能也不够，我们必须开始向下寻找，即使我们没有自己的孩子，也可能是我们正在向下寻找我们的侄子或侄女，或者我们表亲的孩子，如果成为家庭的一部分对你很重要，那么你几乎需要调整你的目光，因为你知道，我作为一位在世父母的女儿与你交谈，这确实改变了事情，然而我确实经历了更多的横向联系，这是一种非常奇怪的生存主义，就像《恋爱时代》对我来说，是我对生存主义焦虑的第一次启蒙。
grow, rather than looking up for our family connections, we begin to have to look across. But then ultimately that might not be enough either and we have to start looking down and even if we don't have our own children it might be that we're looking down to our nephews or our nieces or kind of our cousins children and if being part of a family is important to you then you almost need to readjust your gaze because you know I speak to you as the daughter of one living parent and it does just alter things and yet I definitely have experienced more of the sideways you know connections and it's a very is a very strange existential like Dawson's Creek is for me, my first grounding
这是我一次又一次回到的地方，这在今天可能不是一个很受欢迎的文化参考。但它只是，这是一个完整的过程，不是吗？是的，绝对是。我认为当我们经历如此大的变化时，也许如果我们失去了亲密的家庭成员，我们可能需要调整并思考，你知道，我现在在生活中处于什么位置，我如何能满足那些，如果，你知道，家庭和人际关系
in kind of existential angst. And it's what I come back to time and time again, which probably isn't a very popular cultural reference these days. But like it's just, it's a whole process, isn't it? Yeah, definitely. And I think when we are going through such a big change, perhaps if we lose a close family member, we may need to adjust and think about, you know, where I am in life now, how can I meet those sort of, if, you know, family and relationships
对你很重要，这对我们许多人来说确实如此，你知道，思考我如何能调整。实际上，如果你觉得你无法调整，或者也许作为一个社会，我们并没有真正谈论这些事情，也许和家人有时我们会谈论，或者当发生那样的事情时我们会谈论，但不是每天都谈论，我认为这有点遗憾，因为那些需要支持的人去哪里呢？当然，治疗是一个思考它的绝佳机会，但即使作为临床心理学家，我们也不经常接受如何进行这些对话的培训，除非人们正在经历姑息治疗。我认为这就是困难出现的时候。你知道，如果你试图调整，但没有围绕死亡调整的正确支持，
are important to do, which for so many of us they are, you know, think about how can I adjust. And actually, if you feel like you're not able to adjust or perhaps as a society we don't really speak about these things, perhaps with family sometimes we do or when there's an event like that that happens we do speak about it but not so much day to day and I think it's it can be a bit of a shame because where do people that need to support for that go and of course therapy is a fantastic opportunity to think about it, but even as clinical psychologists, we're not often trained in how to have these conversations outside of people going through palliative care. And I think that's when the difficulties can come up. You know, if you're trying to adjust but not having the right support around the adjustment to death
甚至反思你自己的死亡率，那么你就会开始错误地管理这些恐惧。是的，实际上在临床上，它出现的频率可能比我们想象的要高，但如果我们没有不断挖掘，然后呢，然后呢，然后呢，然后呢，特别是对于强迫症（OCD），如果你不断挖掘，不断挖掘，不断挖掘，然后呢，然后呢，然后呢，你通常会得出，好吧，我担心我会死，而且会很可怕，会很痛苦，而且是可以预防的，每个人都会说，好吧，你本可以这样做或应该那样做。所以实际上，是的，就像你说的，我认为它确实会出现，但我们并不总是拥有，
and reflecting even on your own mortality, then you can start to mismanage those fears. Yeah, and actually clinically, it might crop up more than we think it does, but if we haven't kept digging, and then what, and then what, and then what, and then what, especially with OCD, if you keep digging, keep digging, keep digging, keep then and what, and then what and then what, you often will get to, well, I worry that I'm going to die and it's going to be horrendous and it will be painful and it will be preventable and everyone will say, well, you could have done this or should have done that. And so actually, yeah, like you said, I think it does crop up, but we haven't always got,
就像你说的，完全正确，我们没有培训或技能来处理它，或者它感觉不够临床，你知道，绝对在目前我们拥有的准入阈值的服务中，你知道，如果它没有显著影响某人的幸福感，如果它没有给他们带来很多问题，如果它没有，你知道，使他们对自己有风险，或者如果它没有，你知道，使他们对自己或他人有风险，你知道，那么他们很可能不会达到阈值，当然这是他们可以私下探索的事情，但实际上，你知道，你仍然很重要，它仍然有效，你
like you said, exactly, we haven't got the training or the skills to be able to grapple with that or that it doesn't feel clinical enough, you know, absolutely in the services with the access thresholds we have currently, you know, if it's not significantly impacting on someone's well-being, if it isn't giving them lots of problems, if it isn't you know making them risky to themselves or if it isn't, you know, making them risky to themselves or others, you know, then likely they ain't gonna meet the threshold and of course it's something they can explore privately but actually, you know, you still matter, it's still valid, you
不应该受苦，我想当它从仍然能够发挥功能转变为无法继续你的一天并做你实际上需要做的事情时，它就变得更有问题了。是这样吗？是的，我的意思是，完全正确。所以当然，如果像，再次，如果你去，如果你回想那些缓冲器，如果你能够通过，你知道，拥有那些亲密关系或践行你的世界观来缓冲那种焦虑，无论那些世界观是什么，当然，它们会根据一个人的身份而有所不同。如果我们只是没有那些基础力量或我们可以触及的东西，那它就会成为一个问题。就像你刚才说的，死亡焦虑在许多心理健康困难中的跨诊断因素，我谈到了这一点
shouldn't be suffering and I guess it's when it tips from still being able to be functional to then not being able to get on with your day and do the things that actually you need to do. Is that when it becomes more problematic? Yeah, I mean, exactly. Right. So of course, if like, again, if you go and if you think back to the buffers, if you are able to sort of buffer that anxiety through, you know, having those close relationships or living up to your worldviews, whatever those worldviews may be, of course, they're going to be different based on a person's identity. If we just don't have those sort of foundational strengths or those things that we can reach into, that's when it's going to become a problem. And exactly like you were speaking about, that transdiagnostic factor of death anxiety within so many mental health difficulties, and I talked about this
在我论文的概念回顾部分，本质上大多数，如果不是所有心理健康困难都有这种潜在的，你知道，某种，好吧，我会死，某种事情会发生在我身上，或者我生命中的某个人会死，或者死亡过程本身，或者这将如何影响我周围的人，它会很痛苦吗，或者死后甚至会发生什么。所以即使你是宗教人士，并且你觉得也许你没有践行那些价值观，那也会带来一些关于死后会发生什么的非常强烈的恐惧。是的，就在你说话的时候，这让我想到了我父亲的去世，我很幸运我能和他在一起，但看着某人死去是一种特权，如果那是
in part of my conceptual review within the thesis, and essentially most, if not all mental health difficulties have this underlying, you know, something, well, I will die, something will happen to me, or somebody in my life will die, or the process of death itself, or how is this going to impact the people around me, is it going to be painful, or what's even going to happen to me after death. So even if you are religious and you feel like perhaps you're not living up to those values, that can bring on some really strong fears about what's going to happen to you post-death. Yeah, and just as you speak then, it's making me think about my own father's death and I'm very fortunate I was able to be with him but watching someone die is a privilege if that's
你想要的东西，但它也可能是触发性的和创伤性的，你知道。所以是的，他的死亡并不暴力，但它仍然可能是创伤性的。实际上，我不得不进行EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）治疗，以使他生病和死亡的创伤性部分变得平缓，否则那可能会让我害怕我自己的死亡或其他人的死亡。所以这是在思考实际上你所经历的有多少是创伤，有多少只是与特定事物无关的死亡焦虑，你知道？所以这是在试图将两者分开，
something that you want but it's also can be triggering and traumatizing in itself you know. So yes his death wasn't violent but it still can traumatic. And actually I've had to access EMDR to get the kind of traumatic bits of his illness and death to lay flatter because otherwise that moke well have, have made me fearful of my own death or other people's. And so it's thinking about actually how much of what you're experiencing is trauma and how much of this is just death anxiety that's not linked to a specific thing, you know? And so it's trying to separate the two
因为你值得茁壮成长，你值得繁荣。是的，当然。非常感谢你的分享。我想，是的，就像你说的，我想以你所拥有的经验，当然，很多人会有类似的经历，你知道，一个相当痛苦的经历，我认为这就是它可能成为创伤的区别。但我认为在它不一定导致的地方，所以有时我们可以想到这种创伤后成长，但这当然不会发生在每个人身上。它反而可能导致创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的症状。而这当然取决于该人之前拥有的应对方式，这可能是依恋、应对风格等，以及你在记忆中或当该事件发生时所拥有的想法。我认为如果我们能够谈论，并且我认为类似于创伤，如果我们能够谈论并处理这个事件，那么我认为这会让我们的
because you deserve to thrive, you deserve to flourish. Yeah, of course. And thank you so much for sharing that. I think, yeah, like you said, I think with the experience that you've had in an off-course, so many people would have had a similar experience, you know, one that's quite distressing, I think that's the difference of where it could be a trauma. But I think where it doesn't necessarily lead to, so sometimes we can think of this post-traumatic
大脑更容易理解它，找到意义，在治疗中我们也谈论这个“重获新生”的事情，对吧？我认为如果我们考虑存在主义治疗，这也是其中的一部分。在这个过程中，我读了很多欧文·亚隆（Yalom）的书，他谈到的美妙事情之一是，当他与人们及其存在主义担忧和恐惧一起工作时。他说，你知道，如果你回想过去一年的生活，如果你不得不余生每年都重温那一年，你感觉如何？我认为这是一个非常好的切入点，关于你生活中重视什么，你会改变什么？我很高兴你提到了欧文·亚隆。我其实很喜欢他的作品，我第一次接触它是在我接受培训的时候。我想在我第一年的时候，我读了《爱情刽子手》（Love's Executioner），我认为这确实帮助我成长为一名临床医生。但当然，还有《凝视太阳》（Staring at the Sun），他关于死亡焦虑的书，我也觉得非常有趣。而且我有
growth, but that doesn't of course happen to everybody. It can lead to symptoms of post-traumatic stress disorder instead. And that of course depends on the previous coping that the person had, and this could be attachments, coping styles, etc. previously, but the thoughts that you have in during the memory or when that event is happening. I think if we are able to talk through, and similar to trauma I think, if we are able to talk through and process this event then I think it makes it easier for our brains to make sense of it, kind of find meaning and within therapy we also talk about this thing reclaiming your life right and I think it's a little bit of that as well if we were to think existential therapy. I had, during this process process read a lot of books by Yalom
幸参加了他的讲座之一，是远程的，是在疫情期间，我想是2020年。他当时在谈论他的新书，关于他妻子的去世，我想书名叫《死亡与生命》（A Matter of Death and Life）。他是在家里做的，显然他是一位世界著名的精神科医生，看到他如何衰老，实际上在中间他站起来去小便，需要被搀扶，然后蹒跚着走回来，这真的很难，看到人们衰老很难，看到你关心的人变得虚弱很难，即使他们不老，
and one of the wonderful things he talked about was when he works with people and their existential worries and fears. He says you know if you think back to your life over the past year, how do you feel if you had to relive that past year every single year for the rest of your life. And I think that's a really nice kind of opening into what is it that you value about your life and what would you change? I'm so glad you've mentioned Irvin Yolom. I love his work actually and I first experienced it when I was on training. I think in my first year I I read Love's Executioner, which really helped me to develop as a clinician, I think. But then of course, Staring at the Sun, his book on death anxiety, I really found interesting as well. And I had the
但他们的健康状况在下降，看到你爱或关心的人那样真的很难，看到这个我从小读着他的书长大的人衰老，当然，对他妻子的悲伤和失去如此开放和诚实，这对我来说有点震惊。衰老是一种特权，确实是，但它并不总是没有困难。我喜欢这一点，是的，你完全正确。这让我想到了我目前正在读的亚隆的书，书名叫《给心理治疗师的礼物》（The Gift of Therapy）。这确实是他思考这样一个事实，即他已经走到了生命的尽头，他能留下什么样的遗产。我认为在某种程度上，这当然是他那种象征性的，或者甚至是外部的字面上的不朽，因为你知道，继续谈论某人
pleasure of actually going to one of his talks, it was remotely, it was during the pandemic, I think it was 2020. And he was talking about his new book at the time about his wife's death, a matter of death and life, I think it's called. And he was doing it from home and obviously he's a kind of world-renowned psychiatrist and it was interesting to see how his he has aged and actually midway through he got up and went for a wee and kind of needed to be supported and kind of shuffled back and it was it's just really hard it's hard to see people age it's hard to see people that you care about faltering and even if they aren't old
当他们去世时，或者谈论他们所做的工作，这使他们活下去，并思考你讨论的那本书，我想是《凝视太阳》，他也谈到了这种涟漪效应，当我们离开时，你对人们和你周围的人产生了什么样的涟漪效应。好吧，还有另一本书供我查看，因为我以前不熟悉那本，但我会做的是，我会把我们提到的所有书的链接放在节目说明中，或者如果人们在YouTube上观看，放在描述中。正念是保持我们恐怖管理的一种好方法吗？这是一个非常可爱的问题，同样是我在论文中讨论过的事情，我认为
but they have declining health it can be really hard to see that in someone you love or you care about and that was a bit of a shock for me to see this man who, you know, I've grown up reading, aging and of course being so open and honest about his grief and the loss of his wife. And it's a privilege to age, it is, but it's not always without its difficulties. I love that, and yeah, exactly you're right. And it's making me think about the book that I'm reading by Elam at the moment, and it's called The Gift of Therapy. And it really is him thinking about the fact that he's come into the end of his life and what can he sort of leave on as a legacy. And I think in a way that was, of course course his kind of symbolic or maybe even to an external literal mortality because you know, continue to talk about someone
保持我们恐怖管理的一种好方法吗？这是一个非常可爱的问题，同样是我在论文中讨论过的事情。我认为论文主要关注恐怖管理如何描述死亡，或者我们通常如何以回避或相当防御的方式处理死亡意识。但当然还有其他处理我们死亡率的方式，那就是以一种更投入、更反思、更接受的方式。正念是一种非常好的方式，当然正念帮助我们保持当下，接受不舒服的感觉和不舒服的想法，而不试图
when they've passed or about the work they've done that makes them live on and think in the book that you discussed, I think the staring at the sun, he talks about this ripple effect as well, how whilst we may be gone, what's the ripple effect that you've had on people and those around you. Well, there's another book there for me to check out because I wasn't familiar with that one but what I will do is I'll pop all the links to the books that we're mentioning, I'll pop them in the show notes for people or in the description if people are watching on YouTube. Is mindfulness a good way of kind of
逃避它们，而不试图推开它们，这反过来当然会减少焦虑。有一种关于死亡、关于我们自身死亡率的特定冥想，它叫“Mara Nasati”，希望我发音正确，它帮助人们只是坐下来反思他们对自己死亡率、对周围其他人死亡率的想法。从某种程度上说，这当然可以帮助减少人们感到的那种焦虑，而且一开始不会那么容易，对吧？因为它有点像任何一种焦虑。一开始不会容易，但我们变得越舒服，我们越能坐下来面对那些感觉，我们就越能对那些想法和现实变得反思和接受。是的，我认为我们变得越舒服，
keeping our terror management in check? That's a really lovely question, again something that I had discussed throughout the thesis and I think the of keeping our terror management in check? That's a really lovely question, again, something that I had discussed throughout the thesis. And I think the thesis kind of focused on how terror management describes death or how normally we can deal with death awareness in a avoidant or quite defensive way. But there are of course other ways of dealing with our mortality and that is in a more engaging and more reflective, accepting way. And mindfulness is a really nice way of doing that and of course mindfulness helps us stay present and accept uncomfortable feelings and uncomfortable thoughts without trying
我们变得越舒服，我们越能面对自己的静止和安静，并能够调动我们的想法，也许不把它们看作是威胁性的、有害的、危险的。即使是昨天，我在健身房和某人交谈，她经历了一次受伤，我说，她说，我仍然真的很喜欢来健身房。我说，好吧，也许你可以做一些慢一点的事情。你知道，你可以去游泳。看起来太无聊了。太无聊了。你知道，或者也许，你知道，瑜伽或我的，你知道，正念之类的东西或普拉提。哦不，哦不，太慢了。
to run away from them, without trying to push them away and that in turn of course reduces anxiety. There's a specific meditation on death, on our own mortality, it's called Mara Nasati, I hope I'm pronouncing that correctly, which helps people to just sit and reflect on the thoughts that they have coming up for them about their own mortality, about other people's mortality around them. And in a way that can of course help reduce that anxiety that people feel, and it's not going to be as easy at the start right because it's a bit like any kind of anxiety. It won't be easy to start off with but the more we become comfortable and the more we sit through with those feelings, the more reflective and accepting we can become of those thoughts and that reality. Yeah and I think the more comfortable we become with our own
因为我不能只是，哦，我的大脑会飞速运转。就像是，好吧，这几乎证明了实际上这正是你所需要的，因为独自一人是可以的。那不需要感到威胁。实际上我过去确实，我必须承认，我在培训中承认我退出了我的正念课程，因为它太过了。我被要求在自己的时间里做太多事情，独自在黑暗中躺上半小时。在那一阶段的职业生涯中，我有我想以不同方式做的事情。
And I think the more comfortable we become with our own stillness and the quietness and being able to tune into our thoughts and to maybe not think about them as as threatening, harmful, dangerous. Even yesterday I was talking to someone at the gym and she's experienced an injury and I was like, she's like, I still just really love coming to the gym. And I said, well, maybe you could do something a bit slower. You know, you could go swimming. Just look so boring. So boring. You know, or maybe, you know, yoga or my, you know, mindfulness stuff or palates. Oh no, oh no, too slow.
因为我当时正处于你现在所处的阶段，不得不去大学，而那些没有选择这个免费课程的人却不用去。所以感觉这根本不是我签名的内容。我以为这只是一个额外的东西，就像，你知道，我们可以做的。但不，这现在感觉像是一种惩罚。所以我开始怨恨那种练习。这根本不是我当时所需要的。但实际上，也许只是我当时还没准备好。实际上，是的，就像调动我们的静止和意识可以在你准备好时到来，我想。但有时当，特别是当生活感觉如此嘈杂时，你知道，这些风扇总是握在我们手中。即使在这个播客期间，我也收到了一条LinkedIn通知，
Cause I'm not just be, oh, my mind would be racing. And it's like, okay, it's almost like evidence that actually this is kind of what you need because it's okay to be by yourself. That doesn't need to feel threatening. And actually I did used to, I have to confess, I confess in training I quit my mindfulness course because it was just like it was too much. I was asking this to do too much in my own time, lying down for like half an hour by myself in the dark. Like I had things I wanted to do differently at that stage of my career.
过来关注我，联系我。有人试图给我打电话。我不得不知道那个。我收到了一条短信。我听到了，在我的电脑上，我听到了几声WhatsApp的叮当声，这太多了，你知道，我们绝对需要能够有一些界限，一些时间，一些属于我们自己的空间。我们不是被设计成一直处于这种状态的。是的，你说得完全正确，我们一直处于一种“做”而不是“存在”的状态，对吧？然后我想知道这与我们许多人持有的这些文化世界观有何联系，特别是在西方，那种“奋斗文化”，我们是否在践行这种奋斗文化？我们做得够多吗？我们有成效吗？也许在和别人比较？当然，我们知道
Cause I was literally at the stage that you are at now and having to go into university on days that people who were not opting into this free course were not doing. And so it felt like this is not what I signed up for. I thought this would just be an extra thing, like, you know, that we could just do. But no, this now feels like a punishment. And so I then started to resent that practice. And it was just, it's just not what I needed at that time. But actually, it was maybe just I wasn't ready for that at that time. And actually, yeah, like tuning into our stillness and our awareness can come when you're ready for it, I think. But sometimes when, especially when life feels so noisy, you know, these fans are always in our hand. Even during this podcast, I've had a LinkedIn notification
社交媒体是一个高光时刻的集合。但那对我们做了什么？如果我们觉得我们没有达到那个标准，那对我们的自尊和心理健康有什么影响？我认为这是一个很好的方式来思考实际上，那种死亡意识以及我们思考它的能力，你已经理解了我们无论如何都在经历的这些更广泛的问题，你是完全正确的，有时间只是“存在”或专注于对我来说重要的事情。我在论文中谈论的一件事是那种更深层的死亡参与与那种防御性的、短暂的死亡意识之间的区别，我们试图推开我们关于
come up, come and follow me, connect me. I've had someone try and call me. I've had to know that. I've had a text message. I've had, I've heard on my computer, I've heard a couple of WhatsApp pings, like it's a lot, you know, we absolutely need to be able to just have some boundaries, some time, some space for ourselves. We weren't designed to be this on all the time. Yeah you're exactly right we are constantly in a state of doing rather than being right and then I wonder how that links to these cultural worldviews that many of us hold especially here in the West that sort of hustle culture and are we living up to this hustle culture? Are we doing enough? Are we being productive? perhaps comparing ourselves to other people? And of course, we know that
死亡或死亡率的想法。研究实际上表明，虽然这对每个人来说都不是一个警钟，但有些人从这种更深层的死亡率参与中受益更多，而且似乎是那些具有更高正念、更高心理灵活性、更高好奇心的人。在一个特定的实验中，当他们询问人们关于他们的目标以及外在与内在目标时，那些能够更深入地参与死亡的人实际上最终将内在目标评价得比以前更重要。所以像健康、人际关系和幸福感之类的事情。但如果我们有那些关于死亡率的短暂提醒，或者
social media is a highlight reel. But then what is that doing to us? And if we feel like we're not meeting that, then what's that doing to our self-esteem and mental health? And I think it's a nice way of thinking about actually how then that death sort of awareness and our ability to think about that, you've understood these wider issues that we're experiencing anyway and you're exactly right having time to just be or focus on what is important to me. And one of the things that we talked about or what I talked about in the thesis was this difference between that deeper death engagement and compared to that defensive sort of brief mortality awareness where we're trying to push away our thoughts of
那组中那些有短暂死亡率提醒的人，他们更有可能将那些外在目标，如名声、金钱、财富，所有这些事情评价得更重要。绝对是。听你说话，实际上，它让我想到了我自己的死亡率。它让我想到了我已经为此做的一些计划。其中之一是，写一份遗嘱。我们是在所谓的“英国遗嘱援助月”（UK Will Aid Month）期间做的，我知道今年10月就要到了。那是你让受过培训的法律专业人士免费起草遗嘱，以换取慈善捐款。所以如果任何正在听这个或看这个的人还没有遗嘱，它的成本不一定需要高得令人望而却步。而且它真的很重要，特别是
death or mortality. And what the research is showing actually is that there's, whilst it's not a wake-up call for everybody, there are some people who benefit more from having this deeper engagement of mortality and that it seems to be people with higher mindfulness, higher psychological flexibility, higher curiosity. And when in one specific experiment when they ask people about their goals and extrinsic versus extrinsic goals, those people who got to engage more deeply with their death actually ended up rating intrinsic goals. So things like health, relationships and just wellbeing as more important than previously. But if we had those brief reminders of mortality or
如果你没有结婚，或者特别是如果你没有结婚，或者特别是如果你结婚了但你们不再在一起，你不想让你的遗产传给你的配偶，或者如果你对你的遗产部分去向有非常具体的要求，实际上知道这一切都设置好了是另一件可能有帮助的事情，或者肯定会在你离开后帮助人们。但作为治疗师，我们可能想考虑拥有“治疗遗嘱”。当我们去世时会发生什么，
the people that in that group that had the brief reminders of mortality, they're more likely to rate those extrinsic goals like fame, money, wealth, all of those things as more important. Absolutely. And just listening to you talk actually, it makes me think about my own mortality. And it makes me think about some of the planning that I have already done for that. And one of those things is, is to have written a will. And we did that during something called the UK Will Aid Month, which I know is coming up in October this year. And that's where you get trained legal professionals to draw up a will for free in exchange for a charitable donation. And so if whoever is listening to this or watching this doesn't yet have a will, its cost doesn't necessarily need to be prohibitive in that. And it is really important, especially
如果我们有未结案的案例，谁应该处理它？所以我认为对于在帮助行业工作的人来说，有所有这些关于死亡率的额外考虑层面。你有遗嘱吗，Tia？我可以问你吗？我其实自己没有遗嘱，但我认为这是一个非常重要的话题。我不知道遗嘱援助月，所以我可能会考虑一下。我真的很喜欢你的，是的，我没有考虑过实际上如果
if you are not married, or especially if you are not married or especially if you are married but you are no longer together and you don't want that you know your estate to pass to your spouse or if you have very specific requests about where you want portions of your estate to go and actually knowing that that is all set up is is another thing that might help or certainly help people when you've gone. But also as therapists, we might wanna think about having therapeutic wills. So what happens when we die,
发生了什么事，我们将如何处理结束治疗，那会对我们合作的客户产生巨大的影响，那一定非常令人不安。我认为这就是为什么它如此重要，再次，我论文的很大一部分重点是我们没有足够地谈论这些对话，我真的很感激能讨论这个回顾，再次非常感谢你邀请我来这里，只是为了提高这种意识，并希望让人们思考这不是一个正常的对话，只是为了让它更容易获得。是的，它应该被正常化，不是吗？非常感谢你的到来，非常感谢你介绍这个话题。还有一个，将会有一个小小的死亡，一个死亡迷你系列，我必须说。所以这是第一集。
if we have open cases to us, who should handle that? And so I think there's all these extra layers of mortality considerations for people working in helping professions. Have you got a will, Tia? Can I ask you that? I don't actually have a will myself, but I think this is such an important topic to think about. And I wasn't aware of the will aid month, so I might have a think about that. And I really liked your, yeah, I hadn't considered actually how would we deal with ending therapy if
如果我们手头有未结案的案例，应该由谁来处理？所以我认为对于从事助人行业的人来说，还有所有这些关于死亡的额外考量。Tia，你立遗嘱了吗？我可以问你这个问题吗？其实我自己也没有立遗嘱，但我认为这是一个非常值得思考的重要话题。我之前并不知道“遗嘱援助月”，所以我可能会考虑一下。我真的很喜欢你的观点，是的，我之前确实没有考虑过，如果发生什么事，我们该如何结束治疗。
something did happen to us and that would have such a huge impact on the clients that we work with and that must be really unsettling. And I think this is why it's so important and again a huge part of my thesis focused on we don't have these conversations enough and I'm just really grateful to be able to discuss this review and thank you so much again for having me on here to just to raise this awareness and get hopefully people to think about that this isn't a normal conversation to have and just to make it more accessible. Yeah it should be normalized shouldn't it and thank you so much for being here thank you so much for introducing this topic. There is another there's going to be a little death a death mini I have to say. So this is episode one.
如果我们真的发生了什么意外，那会对我们服务的客户产生巨大的影响，这一定非常令人不安。我认为这就是为什么这件事如此重要，而且我的论文很大一部分重点就在于我们没有进行足够的此类对话。我非常感谢能有机会讨论这个议题，再次非常感谢你邀请我来这里，以提高人们的意识，并希望让大家意识到这不是一个常规的对话，只是为了让它变得更容易被接受。是的，这应该被常态化，不是吗？非常感谢你的到来，非常感谢你引入这个话题。还有一个，将会有一个关于死亡的小系列，我必须说。所以这是第一集。
Episode two is actually looking at the palliative decisions that are happening in court and what the implications are for people, but also what the implications are for us working in mental health services. So if anyone is enjoying this conversation, please do look out for the next episode, which if you're watching this live is coming out next week, or if you are watching just as a general series, look out for it and watch or listen to that one. So thank you so much for your time, Tia.
第二集实际上是在探讨法庭上正在发生的姑息治疗决策，以及这对人们意味着什么，同时也探讨了这对我们在心理健康服务领域工作的人意味着什么。所以，如果有人喜欢这次谈话，请务必关注下一集。如果你是在直播时观看，下一集将于下周发布；如果你是作为系列节目观看，也请留意并观看或收听那一集。非常感谢你的时间，Tia。
Congratulations on getting to the end of your training and wishing you the very best with what comes next. Thank you so much. Thank you so much for having me here and wishing you the best too. Thank you so much. Bye, Tia. Bye bye.
祝贺你完成了培训，并祝你未来一切顺利。非常感谢。非常感谢你邀请我来这里，也祝你一切顺利。非常感谢。再见，Tia。再见。
Oh what a lovely, lovely guest episode that was. I hope you found it helpful. If you have, please drop a comment, drop a like, rate and review the episode or the show. It would be so gratefully received. Thanks to Tia for her time and congratulations on getting to the stage of her career that she's at. If grief is not your special area of knowledge or expertise, or if you would like to up your levels of insight and awareness into it, please do check out my book, The Grief Collective – Stories of Life, Loss and Learning to Heal. There will be links in the show notes and in the description but it gets lovely reviews and it's such a nourishing, wholesome, inspiring read and if you love people and their stories it gives you an
哦，这是一期多么可爱、多么棒的嘉宾访谈啊。希望你觉得有帮助。如果有的话，请留下评论、点赞、评分并评价这一集或这个节目。我们将不胜感激。感谢Tia抽出时间，并祝贺她达到了职业生涯的这个阶段。如果悲伤不是你的专业领域或专长，或者如果你想提高对它的洞察力和认识，请务必看看我的书《悲伤集体——关于生命、失落和学习治愈的故事》。节目笔记和描述中会有链接，它获得了很好的评价，是一本非常滋养、有益、鼓舞人心的读物。如果你喜欢人和他们的故事，它为你提供了一个
excellent chance to have a peek behind the curtains of real people's lives and experiences so it's definitely one not to miss. All of the books that we mentioned including The Grief Collective there'll be links for in the description and the show notes. What has this episode brought up for you? Let's get involved in the YouTube comments, let's support one another, let's inspire conversations. To quote Jack from Titanic, let's make this count. is the aspiring psychologist Pascals without a Marian Dread Hello, my name is Veronica Kasova.
绝佳的机会去一窥真实人们的生活和经历，所以绝对不容错过。我们提到的所有书籍，包括《悲伤集体》，在描述和节目笔记中都会有链接。这一集给你带来了什么启发？让我们参与到YouTube评论中来，让我们互相支持，让我们激发对话。引用《泰坦尼克号》中Jack的话，让我们让这一切变得有意义。这里是渴望成为心理学家的Pascals，没有Marian Dread，你好，我叫Veronica Kasova。
I live in Edinburgh and I just graduated with a Masters in Psychology of Mental Health. Marion recommended me the Clinical Psychologist Collective when I was networking on LinkedIn and I must say I love it. It is one of a kind. It's like a window into the lives of people on the path of becoming a psychologist. The stories are unique, honest and filled with a kind of intangible wisdom only personal storytelling can uncover. A common thread in the stories I valued most was to be compassionate not only with others but
我住在爱丁堡，刚获得了心理健康心理学硕士学位。当我在LinkedIn上建立人脉时，Marian向我推荐了《临床心理学家集体》，我必须说我非常喜欢它。它是独一无二的。它就像一扇窗户，让我们看到了那些走在成为心理学家道路上的人们的生活。这些故事独特、诚实，充满了只有个人叙事才能揭示的那种无形的智慧。我最看重的故事中一个共同的主题是，不仅要对他人富有同情心，还要
with myself too. Also not fixating on becoming a psychologist, but enjoying life, growth and the final results will come as a by-product. Marianne, thank you for taking the time to collate all the stories. The book is a true gem and I think every aspiring psychologist should have a copy on their shelf. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对自己也富有同情心。此外，不要执着于成为一名心理学家，而是要享受生活、成长，最终的结果会作为副产品自然到来。Marian，感谢你花时间整理所有的故事。这本书是一颗真正的宝石，我认为每一位有抱负的心理学家都应该在书架上放一本。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。